That was,
it was,
uh,
again,
anybody get a chance to go see,
go see a show because this one was my Netflix.
You can see that thing now.
You got to pay more for Netflix now.
Yeah.
What is it like 10 bucks?
Yeah,
17% more.
I think they're going to charge.
They can
so much good shit though.
Like if you want to just waste your life and sit in front of the TV,
it's crazy.
Like when we were kids,
maybe that's your passion.
So you get that universal basic income.
And my following my passion means I got to sit and watch every episode of Andy
Griffith Fart under the sheets.
And there's a lot of people doing that right now.
I don't know if that's bad is,
I mean yes it is,
but then doesn't that open the door for the people that aren't going to be like
that?
Like look,
less people out there really actually trying to get ahead.
I think the people that are going to try to succeed are always going to try to
succeed.
I think that's true.
And I think so.
I think that's,
maybe that's an argument against it also,
which has said like,
I don't think it's going to unlock a whole treasure trove of innovators,
right.
If suddenly you give people money and say,
okay,
you don't have to go pour coffee or,
or flip burgers or you know,
clean up that road or whatever you're gonna do for a living,
you can follow your passion.
I don't think we're going to find some exponential increase in the number of
people inventing the wheel.
I just think that it's just going to be a lot more people farden under the
blankets or something.
I don't know.
They might be right,
but the only good that I think could come out of it as a less people are an
abject poverty and less people were desperate.
So it might reduce crime.
You might have lazy people,
but you might also have less people that are inclined to steal things or do
something that's illegal because their basic needs are taken care of.
Yeah.
So that's a valid point.
I read something that's,
it stunned me.
It was,
it was on a plane flying to la,
to La.
Um,
and I read an article about this,
the strike,
right?
The teachers,
sorry,
that here in Los Angeles,
big strike,
Los Angeles Unified School Authority or whatever it's called.
And it was just before they,
they went on strike,
but it talked about the problems at the school district has,
and I don't know whether this statistic is right.
I read it numerous times because I was so surprised by it.
80% of the,
uh,
families that used the Los Angeles public school system are at the poverty level
or below.
And that means of course,
also that they rely on the free meal assistance,
right.
That the schools provide,
which is kind of what,
what the point of the story was.
Like,
the schools are closed right now.
And so,
you know,
kids aren't getting a chance to eat because they,
that's their only chance to get to eat.
Right.
But that number was stunning.
That's crazy.
Right?
So I don't,
I,
I meant to look into it and do more research to see whether the article is
actually correct or not,
but hey,
it was in the newspaper,
so it must be true.
Right.
I don't know about that.
Anyway.
Uh,
yeah,
he's a disturbing number.
It's a very disturbing number.
But it also talked about how 12%,
I think 12 of all kids that go to high school here in Los Angeles then go on to
college,
12%.
And uh,
it was a similar number that never get out of high school.
And it's even worse than a place like New York City public schools.
So I guess the point being is a public school system is it's dark.
Yeah.
In,
in,
in the larger urban centers,
it's got some real problems.
And I think a lot of those people that are the really sad things,
a lot of those people that are at the poverty line or below work hard,
it's not a lack of motivation and said,
just don't have opportunities.
You don't know what to do.
That not doing it the right way.
They don't have guidance.
They never learned correctly when they were young.
Maybe single parent,
they've,
what's the two or three jobs and,
no,
but,
but look,
California has got all sorts of interesting issues.
I mean there's uh,
you know,
talking to some folks and they said,
uh,
a quarter of the nation's homeless people live here in California.
25% of the nation's homeless people live in California and a place to live.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean,
yeah,
I mean these rain in the last few days,
most of the time it's beautiful weather.
Hey,
can't complain about the weather anyway,
but it is crazy.
And,
and it also talks about how a lot of those people,
they work,
but they're homeless,
right?
The cost of housing.
And so you've got people that have a job,
but they are living in their cars,
right?
Because they can't afford housing,
whether it's in San Francisco or Los Angeles.
Insanity.
Yeah.
That is,
that place is insanity.
So your point about the basic universal income,
I take that point,
I see what that,
you know,
if it was possible to pay for it and uh,
and again,
kind of do this thing where you'd,
you're monitoring this issue of motivation so you're not creating another follow
on generation,
just complete slack acids.
Then I think that's it.
That's a really valid point.
I,
my concern would be people that didn't appreciate it and people that felt
entitled,
like they felt like someone owed them that money.
Now you know,
and you're going to have that.
I mean,
this is the,
this is the biggest problem that people have with socialism and socialist
attitudes that some of these kids that are coming up right now,
they look at what they call income inequality,
what they don't look at his effort inequality.
Like some people put in more fucking work and are smarter.
They've figured their way through the game better than you have been doing it
for 50 years or whatever they brain,
right?
It's not that I couldn't agree with him more in the sense that I,
I never begrudged anybody.
I never got pissed off with a rich person because they were rich.
Right.
I think it,
hey,
that's good.
I'd like to be rich.
Right,
right.
So I might want to talk and find out,
hey,
how'd you do it?
How'd you do it?
And yeah,
it's a system sometimes,
you know,
set up so that once you have some money,
you can get more money.
Well of course the fuck it is.
Yeah.
I mean,
I,
if I have some money,
I can invest that money and make more money if I'm smart about it,
if I do it right,
if you do it right.
But I absolutely,
I don't,
you know,
I don't begrudge the idea that's,
so that's part of it is also fairly steeped in the idea that,
you know,
we're living in a very unique country.
Right.
And I do worry sometimes that,
uh,
people don't,
you know,
I,
even family and I've got some friends and others who just constantly pissing and
moaning about this place.
And I'm thinking,
I spent almost all my life over and shit holes around the world and I,
there is no other place I would rather be as a country.
And I know that's,
you know,
it's jingoistic or whatever.
But,
uh,
honest to God,
I still believe,
and if you go someplace and you talk to somebody in,
in some fifth world,
they will also have,
my experience has been any way,
uh,
maybe you're listening in your experience is different,
but that's the way it works,
uh,
is that they'll think if I go to America,
if I can get to America and I work hard,
I can,
I can be successful.
And that I think is still true.
And that's what I worry about with entitlements and thinks that that may kill
that belief.
And you're right.
Incoming inequality.
Yeah,
that's,
but it's your right,
you work harder now.
It doesn't always happen,
but life's not supposed to be fair.
It's,
well,
it's,
maybe it's supposed to be fair,
but it's not fair.
So sorry.
If it's just supposed to be life,
it's definitely not fair.
Yeah.
It's,
uh,
I,
I completely see your point and I,
and I agree with it.
I think that the real concern is that people don't appreciate already how great
they have and what incredible opportunity to have.
And if we increase w w w we give them more benefits with less effort than you're
going to develop more of this attitude that we find disturbing,
which is people that don't have an appreciation for literally the greatest
experiment in self government.
The world's ever known.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
I,
eh,
but I think also that there's,
there's parts of it that need to be looked at.
Like there's a,
there's an interesting study about,
uh,
about college and,
graduation rates from college for,
uh,
for,
disadvantaged folks.
You know,
and that was again,
why they made it easier for tuition assistance,
right?
So the idea was we want to expand the college ability for everybody,
which is a great idea,
right?
But what they found was they expanded the,
the,
the college opportunity for everybody.
But over the past decade,
decade and a half,
fewer people from the lower income,
uh,
categories have been graduating.
Right?
So you've,
what you've done is you said,
come on in.
It's like,
you know,
it's like a special operators,
right?
If,
if,
if you lower the bar,
right?
Right.
Um,
and this is where I'm going to get in trouble.
Probably I'll talk about the marines and you know,
allowing women into combat elements.
I know,
oh my God,
well what do they do?
You lower the bar [inaudible] you make it.
Okay,
well not enough of them could get through the course.
So I'm going to change the regulations.
And so if you change the regulations,
what they found,
where the college was,
if you,
if you increase that pool of people going,
it doesn't mean that they're going to be successful.
Right.
And now what you've done is you've kind of saddle them with some college debt
and they didn't graduate.
So they're still earning what a high school,
you know,
graduate earns and,
and the,
the system doesn't work.
And so I think sometimes just the idea throwing money at the problem or,
or,
or it doesn't,
it's not helpful if we don't think it through and then assess the results.
So,
but yeah,
that,
that whole marine experiment,
I think they're,
they're catching it late in the chain.
And I think it's good to give people the opportunity to succeed into advance
themselves.
But if you really want to address it as a systemic problem,
you got to get to the root of it,
which is these unbelievably horrible neighborhoods.
And these,
these toxic environments that these kids are growing up and being abused and
being scared and bullied and terrible piss poor education,
you know,
first through all the way up to high school.
That's,
I mean,
that's really where you have to address it.
addressing adjusted at the college level and giving them the opportunity to get
into college and making it easier for them.
It doesn't negate the terrible foundation that's been laid by their life.
But yeah,
and I think that's,
we,
we had this idea that that college should be for everybody.
Right.
And that's okay.
That's great.
And that's,
I think that's where the,
you know,
people like Cortez and Bernie Sanders and others with their idea of free
tuition.
Yes.
You know,
they're thinking,
okay,
wow,
look at Europe.
You know,
there's some countries in Europe have free tuition and hey,
it's,
you know,
it's relatively prosperous and there's nothing wrong with that.
But at the same time,
you know,
I,
I think we,
we don't,
we,
we don't assess the cost and the overall efficiency of an idea sometimes.
And so we just assume and you know,
open it up,
let everybody go,
and somehow this is going to work right.
To our advantage.
And honest to God answer is no.
You know,
I think somebody is better off sometimes,
you know,
go into,
becoming a plumber,
maybe,
maybe an honorable living,
living to create living.
One of the happiest guys I know is my plumber in Boise.
That guy is,
I mean,
he's got it knocked right.
He's always out for hunting season and you know,
he'll call,
I'll say,
look,
I got a,
I got a lake,
right?
My ceilings about the cave.
And he goes,
well,
I'm going hunting.
And sorry,
he's just got,
he's got his own schedule.